Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Janas ist mein Name.
Ich bin Ersten und ich bin sehr zuständig.
Ich benötige zuerst ein paar Ihre Daten.
Danach kommen wir zu Ihrer Beschwerden- und Krankengeschichte.
Das ist in Ordnung?
Ja, klar. Sie müssen ja alles wissen von mir.
Und wie ist Ihre Name?
Mein Name ist Frieder Schneider.
Frieder Schneider
Schneider
Ja, ähm, ich bin ein Mann, Frieder.
Frieder
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vornahung stellen?
Ja, Fr, I, D, E, R.
Frieder Schneider
Das klingt genauso wie Frieder, haben Sie recht, ja.
Ja, genau, Frieder.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ähm, 10, 10, 48.
10, 10, 10, 8, 40.
Ja, okay.
Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m groß und ich wiege meistens um die 89 kg.
Nein, 80.
So, Sie sind 1,78 m.
76?
1,76 m groß?
Ja, und 89 kg.
Genau.
Ja, frieder.
Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe seit einiger Zeit so Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein,
und zwar im Unterschenkel vor allen Dingen,
das fing jetzt vor, ja, eigentlich so ziemlich genau,
vor allem Jahr fing das an.
Und dann ist das immer mehr geworden.
Und jetzt tut mit einmal seit 3 Tagen auch der Oberschenkel so doll,
und jetzt habe ich gedacht, oh, jetzt muss ich doch mal her zu Ihnen kommen.
Und wissen Sie, ich habe ein Hund, ich konnte eigentlich immer gut mit dem laufen.
Also ich bin bis vor einem Jahr, konnte ich problemlos mit dem Hund Gassi gehen.
Da sind wir ein Kilometer gelaufen und ich hatte überhaupt gar keine Beschwerden.
Und jetzt ist das so kurz bevor wir nach Hause kommen,
war es immer so, oh, dann tat mir mein Unterschenkel so weh.
Und jetzt mit einmal seit, ja, seit 3 Tagen ist mir das aufgefallen,
dass ich kaum noch gehen kann.
Jetzt kommen die Schmerzen, also schon nach ganz kurzer Strecke.
Ja, seit 3 Tagen im rechten Bein haben sich Schmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Beim Laufen.
Sie müssten warten, wie sich Schmerzen wecken.
Ja, genau, ich muss stehen bleiben und dann gehen die Schmerzen wieder weg
und dann kann ich wieder ein bisschen weiter gehen.
Und gibt es außer Laufen, gibt es einige Situationen,
an denen diese Schmerzen auch getreten sind?
Ja, also oft habe ich auch Nachtschmerzen, wenn ich im Bett liege jetzt in diesem Tag.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0?
Also, wenn ich zu stehen bleiben muss, dann sind die schon ziemlich stark, würde ich sagen.
Also, ich kann das noch aushalten, aber es wird eigentlich seit einem Jahr immer schlimmer.
Aber einfach habe ich gedacht, das geht schon wieder, ja.
Aber jetzt ist es mit einmal so, dass ich dann auch wirklich gar nicht mehr weiter gehen kann.
Ja, ziemlich stark kann man sagen, monter.
Und wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben, z.B. ziehende oder klopfende?
Ja, drückend und auch so ein bisschen brennend stechend auch.
Und ziehen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Ja, eigentlich waren sie immer im Unterschenkel, aber jetzt sind sie eben auch so im Oberschenkel aufgetreten.
Und das zieht dann auch so ein bisschen in die Leiste rein, aber das ist erst neu jetzt.
Und haben Sie Schwelmung am Bein vermehrt oder?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass das Bein geschwollt ist.
Nein.
Oder gibt es Rötungen oder warme Gefühle?
Manchmal kribbelt es so ein bisschen, dass es so nicht so ein bisschen taub anfühlt.
Und Blasser geworden oder?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, aber ich gucke mir die Beine ja auch nicht so genau an.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, dass die Haut so ein bisschen schuppig geworden ist, besonders an dem rechten Bein.
Was meinen Sie mit schuppig?
Dass die Haut so oben sich so abschuppt und die Fußnägel brechen mir auch so ab.
Vielleicht haben Sie auch Haarausfall gemerkt.
Das stimmt.
Sonst hatte ich da immer Haare an den Beinen und die habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Und auch etwas kühler geworden, vielleicht?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas beschwerden?
Ja, die Schmerzen im Bein reichen mir völlig aus. Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Haben Sie Luftmaus oder Husten?
Das habe ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Haben Sie Brutzschmerzen?
Meine Brust, nein, ein Bein tut mir weh, nicht die Brutzschmerzen.
Ja, okay. Und haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich auch nicht fieber.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, zurzeit schlafe ich nicht so gut.
Die letzten Monate bin ich oft nachts wach.
Einmal muss ich auf die Toilette nachts.
Das hängt mit dem Alter zusammen.
Ein bis zweimal in der Nacht muss ich auf die Toilette gehen.
Ein bis zweimal in der Nacht.
Dann habe ich auch die Schmerzen im Bein.
Da muss ich dann auch ein bisschen rumlaufen, dass es besser wird.
Bekommen Sie gut Luft, wenn Sie flach liegen?
Ja, ich lege eigentlich immer relativ flach im Bett.
Ich habe zwar so ein, zwei Kissen, dass es gemütlich ist,
aber ich kann gut Luft kriegen.
Schwitzen Sie nachts?
Nein, ich habe nicht aufgefallen, nur als es jetzt sehr warm war.
Da habe ich nachts ein bisschen geschwitzt, aber normalerweise schwitze ich nicht mehr.
Okay, in der letzten Zeit haben Sie ab oder zugenommen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich wiege mich aber jetzt auch nicht so oft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Sachen passen mir alle noch.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen, z.B. Zucker?
Klar, in meinem Alter.
Das weiß man ja.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren Diabetes.
Das weiß ich wohl.
Da nehme ich so ein Medikament, das heißt Medformin.
Wie stark ist das?
Ich meine, da steht 800 drauf und dann nehme ich morgens und abends ein.
Ja, und sonst noch?
Ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich natürlich auch.
Bleib warm.
Das hat man schon vor 20 Jahren festgestellt.
Und diese Beide sind gut eingestellt, z.B. ihre Blutzucker oder Blutdruck.
Wie viel ich weiß, ist das alles immer, wenn ich da bin, ganz gut.
Und dann kriege ich noch irgendwas.
Ich glaube, das ist gegen Blutfette.
Ich nehme immer noch Simvastatin ein.
Ich glaube, das ist für die Blutfette.
Simvastatin 20 oder 40?
20 ist das.
20 und abends?
Das nehme ich einmal abends, genau.
Und für gegen Blutdruck, was nehmen Sie ein?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich nehme mich da überhaupt irgendwas ein.
Ich glaube, ich nehme da gar nichts ein.
Also, so hoch ist der aber auch nicht.
Okay.
Und diese erhöhte Blutfettwerte, wann haben Sie?
Ich glaube, das hat man zusammen mit dem Diabetes festgestellt.
Und das war es, oder?
Ja, also vor vielen Jahren hatte ich mal so eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung.
Und seitdem nehme ich auch noch Aspirin.
Und ich nehme auch noch Klopidogreel.
Was hat man diagnostiziert?
Ja, irgendwie waren die Gefäße ein bisschen verstopft.
Da hat man deiner Zeit ein Stent gelegt.
Aber seither habe ich da eigentlich keine Probleme mehr.
Genau.
Das ist jetzt 15 Jahre her.
15 Jahre.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Und diese Klopidogreel, wie stark ist das?
Ich meine, das ist Klopidogreel 75.
Da nehme ich einmal.
Und diese Aspirin?
Auch Aspirin 100, das was alle nehmen, einmal am Tag.
Und dann am Morgen, oder?
Okay.
Also sie nehmen mit Formin, Simastatin, Aspirin und Klopidogreel ein, oder?
Ja, genau.
Und das war es.
Ja, das ist ja mehr als genug.
Braucht man jetzt schon keinen Zustand?
Ja, genau.
Und würden Sie sich schon einmal operieren?
Ja, außer dieser Herz.
Ja, aber ich habe es noch nie operiert worden.
Und Herr Schneider rauchten Sie?
Ja, ich habe früher mal geraucht.
Aber das habe ich jetzt im Alter sein gelassen.
Auch als es dann mit dem Herzen war, da hat man mir geraten,
ich soll das mit dem Rauchen sein lassen.
Ja, also.
Das hat mir eigentlich auch nie so gut geschmeckt.
Ja, und?
Und dann haben Sie abgesetzt.
Ja, das ist jetzt schon so 15 Jahre her.
So 15 Jahre.
Mhm.
Und diese Herzkartiertau, oder?
Genau, ja, ja.
Das war so ein Schuss vor dem Buch.
Und da habe ich dann gesagt, ja, jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen auf.
Genau.
Und wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Oh.
Ich habe, wissen Sie, ich war Gastwirt.
Ich habe in der Kneipe gestanden den ganzen Tag.
Da habe ich viel geraucht.
Also 40 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
40.
40 Jahre ist so viel.
Und ungefähr wie viel am Tag?
Ja, das kommt drauf an, wie viele Leute da im Laden waren,
was da gerade los war.
Also zwischen einem Halden und einem Päckchen am Tag habe ich geraucht.
Mhm.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also früher habe ich natürlich mehr getrunken,
als ich noch die Kneipe hatte,
aber jetzt trinke ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr viel.
Noch so, wenn ich mich mit meinen Freunden treffe zum Karten spielen
oder so, dann trinken wir noch mal einen.
Also, dass ich jetzt zu Hause regelmäßig mal ein Bier
oder mal ein Schnäpschen, aber nicht wirklich viel.
Jeden Tag?
Nein, ganz bestimmt nicht jeden Tag.
Ja, von zu oder?
Ja, also ich würde jetzt sagen 2-mal in der Woche,
3-mal in der Woche.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben in der Kneipe arbeitet.
Ja, ich war Gastwirt, ich war selbstständig.
Gastwirt.
Mhm.
Aber jetzt bin ich natürlich in der Rente, ne?
Sie haben eine eigene Kneipe oder so.
Ja, das war meine eigene Gastwirtin.
Ja.
Ja, und?
Ja, und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin verwitwit, meine Frau ist verstorben.
Ja, tut mir leid.
Darf ich fragen, warum?
Warum?
Weil, sie hatte Lungenkrebs.
Sie hatte Lungenkrebs.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir hatten keine Kinder.
Und gibt es Ihre Familie,
irgendwelche Kronscherkrankungen,
wie Diabetes oder?
Ja, also gesunden sind die alle nicht mal.
Also meine Eltern, die sind beide nicht alt geworden.
Mein Vater hatte mit 60 in Herzinfarkt
und meine Mutter hatte mit 60 Jahren.
Ja, Herzinfarkt.
Und ist da dran gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, das ist auch blöd gelaufen,
die hatte Lungenembolie.
Und ist da auch daran gestorben.
Und da war sie erst 75.
75.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich gar nicht.
Ich war immer alleine.
Deswegen lebe ich jetzt auch alleine, meine Frau ist tot.
Keine Geschwister.
Ich habe nur noch meinen Hund, mit dem ich regeln muss, rausgeblieben.
Ja, und Sie möchten weiterlaufen?
Ja, natürlich.
Der muss heraus, der Hund.
Der wartet ja auch auf mich zu Hause.
Genau, genau.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Was sind alle meine Fragen?
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas?
War Ihnen sonst noch etwas eingefallen?
Ich habe Ihnen, glaube ich, so viel erzählt.
Sie haben mich ja auch viel gefragt.
Ich glaube, also, was ich jetzt natürlich wissen will,
was kann man gegen diese Schmerzen machen?
Und woher kommt das überhaupt?
Ja, so, ja, mit Ihre Beschwerden-Sprücken
für eine Gefäserkrankung.
Und Sie haben schon eine Herzkranzgefäße Verengung.
So, wenn man eine Gefäßerkrankung in Ihrem Körper gibt,
gibt es mehrere.
Und zwar, ich glaube, Sie haben auch
Ihre rechten Beinengefäße.
Ach, genauso wie ich das im Herzen hatte,
dass ich das auch im Bein habe.
Genau, genau.
Und ich möchte eine Somographie machen.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob diese Durchblutung gestört ist
oder nicht.
Und ich gebe Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel.
Das ist schon mal gut, ja.
Ja, und ich möchte auch in ein Blutabnehmen für das Labor.
Und dann, wenn alle Befünder vorliegen,
können wir wieder sprechen.
Okay, ja, das klingt doch vernünftig.
Aber muss ich denn wohl hierbleiben?
Was meinen Sie?
Ja, sobald wir alle Befünde haben,
dann aber, ja, vermute, können Sie heute nach Hause.
Das wäre natürlich gut, da kann ich mich um meinen Hund kümmern, ne?
Genau.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Schneider, wissen Sie, wie viele Meter
beschwerden frei laufen?
Wie gesagt, früher konnte ich ein Kilometer problemlos laufen.
Dann habe ich gesagt, kurz vor dem Heim gehen.
Also, 800 Meter war dann die Strecke.
Okay.
Jetzt akut, also nur 100 Meter.
Ja, sehr gut.
Herr Schneider, haben Sie Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen damit?
Jetzt, im Augenblick nicht, nein.
Mit meinem Herz, das ist ja alles wieder gut,
seit ich da diesen Stand habe.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ja, klar.
Ich war ja wegen Corona, bin ja zum Impfen gewesen.
In meinem Alter war das ja ganz wichtig, ja.
Okay.
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie Ausland gereist?
Ich bin nicht ins Ausland gereist.
Nein, da komme ich ja gar nicht hin.
Nein, nein.
Okay, danke.
Ich denke, eine...
Eine Nagell...
Noch mal, wo?
Merklich Veränderung?
An Ihrem Fußnagen.
An den Fußnägel.
Ja, das habe ich gesagt, dass die Nägel brüchig werden.
Danke.
Haben Sie ruhig Schmerzen?
Ruhig Schmerzen hat er nicht.
Ja, das einzige, also er beschreibt ja,
dass er Schmerzen, wenn er im Bett liegt, hat.
Das ist aber nicht regelmäßig,
aber so, normalerweise keine ruhige Schmerzen.
Aber das ist ja früher ein bisschen geschwärmt.
Ja.
Ach so, ja, gute Frage.
Nee, also mit den Beinen hatte der bisher noch keine Schmerzen.
Danke.
Wir haben Standard-3-Fragen immer stellen müssen.
Wir müssen immer 3 Standard-Fragen stellen.
Lieber Dr. Kübis.
Und jetzt, welche?
Eins, sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen als gewesen.
Zweite, haben Sie einen Unfall.
Dritte, Sie haben schon gesagt, aber wir müssen fragen.
Und unser Kollegen hat gefragt.
Was war das Dritte?
Dritte hat...
Was wäre jetzt das Dritte, was man der Vollständigkeit halber fragen muss?
Einmal...
Alles verstehe.
Unfall.
Ja, also Trauma. Trauma auszunehmen.
Und ein Arztbesuch.
Arztbesuch, ja.
Und schon einmal auftreten oder erst mal auftreten.
Genau, genau.
Aber jetzt ist er hier, weil die Beschwerden akut geworden sind.
Deswegen hat er sich im Krankenhaus vorgestellt.
Aber Patient hat vor 15 Jahren einen Möckerkennfall gehabt,
erlitten und einen Stand bekommen.
Und danach eigentlich Beschwerden zum Beispiel...
Ja, also beschreibt er nicht.
So gibt es keine Trauma oder so, Verletzung?
Nein, genau.
Das wäre ja immer noch so, weil Beinschmerzen noch eine wichtige Sache.
Dass man sagt, ja, ich habe sie sich irgendwo gestoßen oder so.
Vielleicht könnte man tatsächlich auch noch fragen, ob es eine offene Wunde gibt am Bein.
Das wäre vielleicht auch noch, wenn jemand, also erhebliche Beinschmerzen schildert,
dass man da vielleicht auch noch auf die Idee kommen kann.
Kraftlosigkeit.
Also er beschreibt ja eigentlich nur, dass er manchmal so ein Kribbeln und Taubheitsgefühl hat.
Das ist ja beschrieben.
Aber Kraftlosigkeit beschreibt er nicht.
Und beschreibt auch keine Trauma und keine offene Wunde.
PMDC, Periphera Motorische durchbüchstörungen.
Wenn ein Patient ihr extrem tät Schmerzen oder Beschwerden haben,
auf jeden Fall.
Könnten wir erstes gespritzt anfangen?
Von mir aus, ja.
Bitte schön, Leine.
Guten Tag.
Janas ist mein Name.
Ich bin Neuererstin aus der Notaufnahme.
Und ich habe gerade einen Patient gesehen.
Und ich möchte ihn vorstellen.
Ich möchte ihn Ihnen vorstellen, ja.
Ihnen vorstellen, ja.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich, gerne.
Herr Frieder Schneider, 74-jährige Patientin kam heute zu uns wegen
Rechte, Beinschmerzen seit 3 Tagen.
Er hat diese Beschwerden seit einem Jahr.
Aber sich verschlimmert.
Sie haben sich verschlechtert.
Er kann nur 100 m laufen.
Seit 3 Tagen.
Bevor die Schmerzen auftreten.
Es gibt einen Fachbegriff, der das sehr schön beschreibt.
Sie haben vorhin gefragt, gehen die Schmerzen weg, wenn sie stehen bleiben.
Wie heißt das?
Wissen Sie garantiert.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht.
Was ist das?
Nein, Claudicacea Intermittent.
Ja, Claudicacea Intermittent hat er begleitet.
Er hat Krebel und Haupaltsgefühl am Fuß.
Er hat auch bemerkt Haupal und Nagelveränderungen.
Außerdem hat er Nectury 1-2 Mal am Nacht.
In der Nacht?
Er hat die Diabetes seit 10 Jahren.
Er nimmt Metformin, Simastatin, ASS, Klopidogal ein.
Als Operationen bekam er einen Stand vor 10 Jahren.
Das ist interventionell.
Er ist Exraucher.
Er ist 50 Jahre alt.
Er hat 20 bis 40 Pakete im Jahr.
Er trinkt 2-3 Mal am Woche Bier.
Er ist ehemaliger Gaswirt, in einer Kneike, verwittelt und hat keine Kinder.
Er ist in der Familie an einem Nase.
Er findet sich beim Vater ein lethaler Neocardinfarkt mit 60 Jahren.
Er ist nicht alt geworden.
Er ist in der Mutter ein Lungenembolie mit 75 Jahren.
Er ist 100 Meter alt.
Er ist 2 Jahre alt.
Er ist 4 Jahre alt.